>> Larry: SO I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS THE TOM BRADY
THING BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
HE WAS PUNISHED, FIRST OF
ALL, HE DID IT.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT.
EVERYBODY AGREES ABOUT THAT,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> NO.
>> YOU'RE NOT LIKE A --
>> YES, YES.
>> PERSONALLY DID IT?
>> HE KNEW ABOUT IT, HE
ORDERED IT.
>> HE CALLED THE GUY, THE
DEFLATOR, SO YES, HE KNEW.
>> EXACTLY.
>> THEY'RE COMPLETELY
THROWN UNDER THE BUS WHO DID
THE DEFLATING.
>> THE 35-YEAR-OLD BALL BOY,
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> 35-YEAR-OLD BALL BOY.
HE IS 35 YEARS OLD, IF YOU
ARE I BALL BOY AT 35 --
>> WHAT AM I GOING TO DO YOU
KNOW, I HAVE BEEN BALL
BOYING FOR 35 YEARS.
>> IF YOU GIVE THE BALLS TO
ANOTHER TEAM THEY'RE GOING
TO-- THIS IS SO DUMB IT IS SO
OVERDONE IT'S RIDICULOUS
>> Larry: SO WHAT IS WORSE
ABOUT THIS, CHEATING OR
LYING?
WHAT ARE WE MORE MAD AT.
>> LYING ABOUT CHEATING I
THINK IS WORSE.
>> YES.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE GOOD AT
LYING IF YOU WANT TO CHEAT.
>> WE LEARNED THAT WATCHING
BILL CLINTON, RIGHT.
IF ARE YOU GOING TO CHEAT,
CHEAT.
BUT THEN THE TELL TRUTH ONCE
YOU GET BUSTED BUT IF YOU
CHEAT AND YOU LIE ABOUT THE
CHEATING, THEN YOU GOT TO
DEAL WITH THE BLUE DRESS AND KEN
STARR REPORT.
>> I LOVE THAT CLINTON
THOUGHT HE HAD A GOOD LIE.
>> HE DID.
>> IT DEPENDS WHAT "IS" IS
>> AM I RIGHT, LADIES?
>> AND EVERYBODY WAS LIKE
NO.
N-O.
>> MORE MAD AT HIM FOR
CHEATING OR LYING.
>> I THINK HE WAS DOING A
SERVICE BECAUSE WITH ALL THE
CONCUSSIONS YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE HIT IN THE HEAD
WITH A HARD OVERINFLATED
BALL.
YOU WANT IT SOFT BALL TO
HIT.
I THINK HE'S DOING A
SERVICE.
>> Larry: DOING A SERVICE
FOR ALL NFL PLAYERS BY DOING
THIS.
>> BUT HE'S ONLY BEING FINED
WHAT $2 MILLION THAT IS
ABOUT-- .
>> Larry: MIGHT ONLY BE $1
MILLION.
>> GISELE WILL PICK UP THE
TAB.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, HE GETS
PAID $2 MILLION TO PUT ON
HEELS, IF HE NEVER WORKS
AGAIN, CAN BE A STAY AT HOME
DAD AND BE KILLING.
>> Larry: I HAVE TO STAY
HOME WITH MY MODEL WIFE.
>> MY HOT MODEL WIVE.
>> MAYBE IF WE WERE TO BEAT
THE BALLS IN AN ELEVATOR
SECURITY CAM THEN HIS-- IT
WOULD BE-- HE WOULDN'T BE
SUSPENDED FOR AS MANY GAMES.
>> HE GOT TWICE THE
SUSPENSION OF RAY RICE.
>> I STILL DON'T THINK THAT
IS THE ENOUGH.
I'M NOT THE BIGGEST
FOOTBALL FAN IN THE WORLD.
I WILL ADMIT THAT.
>> Larry: YOU DON'T THINK
FOUR GAMES IS ENOUGH.
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IF
YOUR JOB IS TO PLAY THE GAME
WITH INTEGRITY IN A
LEGITIMATE WAY, AND YOU
DEFLATE THE BALLS, THAT IS
GIVING YOU AN UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE AND YOU WIN THE
SUPERBOWL AS A RESULT, NO,
YOU DON'T DESERVE TO WIN.
NOT ONLY DO YOU NOT DESERVE
TO WIN, YOU DIDN'T DESERVE
TO PLAY FOR THE ENTIRE
SEASON, I WOULD SAY.
IF THE NFL WAS SERIOUS ABOUT
SECOND A MESSAGE ABOUT THIS
GAME BEING PLAYED FAIRLY
THEY SHOULD SUSPEND HIM.
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY
ARE --
>>
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN NO, THE
ONLY REASON HE'S NOT-- THE
ONLY REASON HE'S IF THE
BEING SUSPENDED IS BECAUSE
HE'S TOM BRADY AND HE MAKES
THE NFL MILLIONS UPON
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> IT SHOULD BE TEN YARDS,
NOBODY CARES.
EVERY PLAYER IN EVERY SINGLE
SPORT CHEATS ON EVERY PLAY.
IF YOU-- EVERY GUARD IS
HOLDING ON TO THE DEFENSIVE
PLAYER EVERY PLAY.
AND IF IT WASN'T ON THE
OUTSIDE THEY GET CALLED IT'S
JUST NOT THAT BIG OF A DEAL.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT IT'S
OKAY --
>> LOOK, MY WIFE AND I GOT
INTO A HUGE ARGUE ABOUT THIS
SO I KNOCKED HER OUT IN THIS
ELEVATOR.
AND.
>> DID YOU HAVE THE DECENCY
TO DRAG HER OUTSIDE THE
ELEVATOR OR DID YOU LEAVE
HER IN.
>> WHY WOULD HE DO THAT.
>> I GOT HALFWAY THROUGH AND
I WAS LIKE I GOT A TEXT
MESSAGE.
>> ARE WE SERIOUSLY JOKE
BEING THIS RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
ARE WE SERIOUSLY JOKING ABOUT
THIS.
>> IT'S LITERALLY COMEDY
CENTRAL.
>> IT IS A CENTRAL PART OF
COMEDY.
>> Larry: IT IS THE CENTRAL
HUB FOR COMEDY, YOU'RE RIGHT
I WANT TO SHOW BRADY'S
DENIAL.
I HAVE TO SHOW THIS.
THIS IS HOW HE DENIED.
>> IS TOM BRADY A CHEATER.
>>
(LAUGHTER)
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
>> Larry: I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
COULD YOU IMAGINE IF-- YOU
HAVE CHEATED ON ME.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
SOMETHING LARRY WILMORE
WOULD DO.
I WASN'T EVEN LISTENING, I
JUST GOT LOST IN HIS EYES.
>> Larry: HOW MUCH OF THIS
IS SCHADENFREUDE?  HOW MUCH OF
IT IS INSTEAD OF A PLAYER
CHEATING, IT IS PLAYER HATING.
PEOPLE JUST WANT TO SEE TOM
BRADY JUST COME DOWN.
>> YEAH, HE'S RICH, HE'S
TALENTED.
GOOD LOOKING, HE HAS A HOT
WIFE.
GET RID OF HIM.
>> THAT TO ME IS ONE OF
THE MOST AMERICAN PARTS OF
THE STORY.
WE DON'T LIKE YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE
TOO MUCH OF A WINNER.
>> HATE ON THE WINNERS.
>> I LOVE HIM.
I THINK-- LOOK, I'M A
SEAHAWKS FAN AND WE SHOULD
HAVE RUN THE BALL ON THAT
LAST PLAY.
WITH AND I STILL-- .
>> Larry: I THINK-- THEY
SHOULD BE SUSPENDED THE
WHOLE SEASON FOR THAT PLAY.
>> THE ONE TRUE PUSHMENT
EVERY TIME YOU GOOGLE HIS
NAME NOW SHRUNKEN BALLS WILL
COME UP.
>> Larry: VERY NICE, I LOVE
IT.
AWESOME.